pain pain pain pain pain pain embrace
the pain pain
hello patience my name is Evan Carmel my
one word is bookie but I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all of the
world's major problems that I hope you
on your journey today we're going to
learn how you can embrace the pain and
also guys if you're watching me hear
something that really resonates you
please leave it down as post below the
quotes around this is my Twitter Fry's
would also be write it down once we let
the distinct joy
[Music]
[Music]
pain is temporary it may last for a
minute or an hour or a day or even a
year but eventually it will subside and
something else will take its place if I
quit however it will last forever
listen to me I'm telling y'all as I
leave telling you as I leave I was
homeless for two and a half years and
the problem with most of you you never
felt no pain before y'all spoil y'all
spoil some of y'all spoil just
bottom-line your parents have done
everything for you you never had to do
nothin for yourself you're spoiled we
don't keep it real tonight some of you
are spoiled black every time you ever
got in trouble somebody in your house
got you out of it every time you done
something you not supposed to do people
say Eric your mother's a tyrant you're
right she kicked me out you're right she
meeting but she developed a minute
because she put me out there and said
you're gonna have to grow up and
somebody would have never learned to
grow up and so every time something get
hard you quit you call mama I dare you
to take a little pain I dare you I dare
you not to go home so my said I don't go
home I feel bad go throw it you ain't
gonna die
at the end of pain and success you're
not going to die because you feeling a
little pain I'm not even like I eat at
home that's why you're about to go
through the next level because if you
can eat like you ate at home you will
keep being a boy or girl it's time to
become a woman
so don't worry about a little pain pain
if necessary if any capable is no way
out of pain we are born pain is a must
pain it is necessity of growth be
comfortable with being uncomfortable
pain as a necessary evil kid used to it
make friends with it and being kicked
pain has and that way when it comes to
take you dancing first er stub I'm used
to him so bring it on come on ain't 6os
down and let's have up lunch too devil
we are you pain let's do it death bring
there's a bunch of people that will say
yeah why family shows you know it's a
great idea for you to just go out there
and go crazy you have people to support
you need to listen
stop saying that stop saying any of
those things every single person who has
ever done anything worthwhile or
exceptional or difficult or
extraordinary anyone whether it's great
artists or authors or mathematicians or
whatever the it is everyone encounters
difficulties there is no easy road it
does not exist it is impossible everyone
has issues if you have time to pursue a
hobby if you have time to do anything in
your life you can better yourself and
here's one way you never better yourself
when you come up with excuses for why
other people are successful in your not
that's dangerous when you give yourself
an escape yeah well that's easy for you
to say you know you do do do-do-do to
trust me everybody has a hard road I
wanted to jump out of windows several
times during my young life I wanted to
jump in front of a train just end it
because too much pressure not really but
you know I'm saying theoretically we all
go through hard times we all go through
depression we all do go through doubt
and then moments in your life where it's
really difficult and you're trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] your path is
going
be it's hard ish but Stefan and I were
talking about this before the podcast
starts that that is what makes you a
person and those difficult moments are
what build your character show me a
great man who's the son of a great man
and that's what we're saying these kids
that are born billionaires your your
you're never going to be a self-made
person you have a back up trust for your
back up trust for your trust and your
man experiencing a pain in your muscles
and aching and just think go on and go
on and gone and this last 2 or 3 or 4
repetitions that's what makes actually
the muscle then grow and it divides in
one from a champion and one from not
being a champion if you can't go through
this pain period you make it to be a
champion if you can go through forget it
and that's the most people like is I'm
just having the guts - guts to go in and
just say I go through and I don't care
what happens you know it aches and if I
fall down I have no fear of fainting in
a gym because I know it could happen I
threw up many times while I was working
out but it doesn't matter because it's
all worth it I one does have to be
focused on the short term and money
coming in when creating company because
otherwise the company will for die so
that I think that a lot of times people
think like creating company is going to
be fun I would say it's not it's really
not that fun when there are periods of
fun and there are periods of
where's-where's just awful and
particularly if you see of the company
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in a company there's
no point in spending your time on things
that are going right so you only spend
on things on your time on things that
are going wrong and they're things that
are going wrong that other people can't
can't take care of so you're like the
worst you have a filter for the crappers
problems in the company
most pernicious and painful problem so I
wouldn't say it's I think you have to
feel quite compelled to do it and have a
fairly high pain threshold and there's a
friend of mine here who says like
starting companies like staring at the
abyss and eating glass and there's some
truth to that we're sharing via best
part is that you're going to be
constantly facing the extermination of
the company because most most startups
fail that's like 90% ugly 99% of of
Starks fail so I so you that's that's so
staring in to give this part you can't
so constantly saying ok if I don't get
this right the company will die should
be quite right for quite stressful and
and then the eating glass parties you've
got you've got to do you've got to do
the problems you gonna so you're going
to work on the problem that the company
needs you to work on that problems you
want to work on and so that the that's
the unit working on problems that that
you could really wish you weren't
working on and so that's the eating
glass part then that goes on for a long
time so how do you keep your focus on
the big picture when you're constantly
faced with we could be out of business
in a month well it's just a very small
percentage of mental energies on the on
the big picture like you know you know
where you generally heading for and and
the factual path is going to be some
sort of zigzagging thing in that
direction it cry not to deviate too far
from the path that you want to be on but
you're going to have to do that some
degree but I don't want to I don't want
to diminish the I mean I think the
product the profit motive is it is a is
a good one if the rules of an industry
are properly set up so there's only
fundamentally wrong with profit in fact
profit just means that people are paying
you more for whatever you're doing then
you're spending to create it that's a
good thing if you're not if that's not
the case then you'll be out of business
and rightfully so
you're not adding effect the key is what
we do in our times of pain pain will
change us heartache lost disappointments
they don't leave us the same when I lost
my father I didn't come out like I was
before I was changed if you go through a
divorce a legal battle a friend betrays
you eventually that will pass you'll get
through it but you will be different now
how the pain changes you is up to you
you can come out bitter or you can come
out better you can come out with a chip
on your shoulder blaming God or you can
come out stronger with a greater
confidence in God you can come out
defeated giving up on your dreams or you
can come out with a new passion a new
fire excited about the new opportunities
in front of you all of us experience
pain my challenge don't just go through
it grow through it that difficulty is an
opportunity to get stronger to develop
character to gain new confidence anybody
can give up anybody can let it overwhelm
you but you know what that's doing
wasting your pain that pain is not there
to stop you it's there to prepare you to
increase you to develop you people used
to take my raps and crunch them up and
throw them on the ground to get made fun
of all the time it's who believes that
the guy sitting next to my math class is
going to blow up become a superstar you
don't like that right but like you
should and it's a bummer you know me
because I yeah I don't know man I mean
take it take it and make you know pain
is the best inspiration so if you're a
creative out there you're getting bully
ticket make something great out of it
have you ever watched a James Bond movie
poor it doesn't what are you losing at
some point and anyways or Batman or Iron
Man or any superhero there has to be
some diversity for you to you know
overcome to win it can't be a champ
unless you are you know in a place where
you look like you're going to lose and
then you win the pain that's going to
come with being independent you have to
because it's going to happen and also
know that the more successful you get
the more problems you're going to have
the more knots you're gonna have to
untie being a boss does not mean smooth
sailing it means having the ability to
care about other people for yourself and
to untie problems on time now that's all
it is there's it's not business if
there's not problem there's nothing good
without struggle it just doesn't happen
and all my experiences there hasn't been
one thing that's been successful without
me feeling some pain before it was
successful so now when there is pain I
embrace it you know I've been embracing
it I'm aji about it because I know that
must mean that if I'm cool and you know
wood away from you like the darkest
before the dawn I don't want to like
sound corny but that's really what
that's what has to happen now I know
that I personally have experienced quite
a bit of disappointment in my life and
I'm assuming that you have as well and
guess what we're going to continue to be
disappointed throughout our lives at
least we should be because if you're not
that means that you're really not trying
now how you handle yourself post
disappointment this is critical to your
emotional and mental well-being
pain pain hurting right it's part of the
growing process but I'll tell you
something life has a funny way of
closing doors in order to keep you
moving in the right direction alright
so often in our society and as people we
run from pain we do everything we can to
protect ourselves and to shield
ourselves from feeling uncomfortable
that feeling of pain and this is the
reason why so many people abuse drugs
alcohol casual sex we do this to not
feel the pain but I'm saying stop
running stop trying to mask it all right
when you feel pain disappointment it's
okay don't try and cover it up what you
should do is actually embrace it I know
it's the it's easy for me sin here
saying oh embrace the pain you're
feeling my crap don't worry about it
feel it feel it I get it right that's
not it's kind of a long shot but what
I'm saying is that the pain is normal
its natural it's a part of the growth
process learn from it once you do you
accept it you embrace it learn from it
put it in its place you're going to be
able to move forward stronger faster
smarter if you're not struggling and
getting disappointed from time to time
this probably means that you're not
really pushing your limits through far
alright it's okay embrace it
don't get discouraged and stay focused
pain is a beautiful thing challenge is
what life is about a life without
challenge a life without pain is a life
without growth and where there is no
growth there's scale stagnant energy and
that's where most people live because
most people's lives are designed around
treading a path that is void of
challenge the minute they recognize
challenge our pain they move the other
way this is a primal instinct and normal
and natural but a weak perspective most
people are bored if you ask them what do
you think about your life the same old
same old every single day what it was
the thing same day same different day
things of this nature that's because
they're living their lives in a lie that
is shrouded in comfort it doesn't exist
they're not challenged they're not
growing they're bored and they're better
off dead your likeness is found in your
pain embrace it love it and grow from it
thank you guys so much you are an elbow
from joy I'd love to know what did you
take from this video that you're going
to immediately a buying up how to your
life is your business leaving downtown
to Louisville from Midland Texas eat
what you have today so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
[Music]